hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to learn how
to interpret a graph which has many
useful applications in biology first
let's look at the parts of a graph every
graph if done correctly should have a
title the title should describe what is
shown on the graph in this case the dark
fur allele frequency and a field mouse
population over time every graph should
also have appropriately labeled axes
there is the x-axis in this case it is
time in years with the years labeled
from 2008 to 2014 every graph also has a
y-axis that is the vertical one
this y-axis is the allele frequency
expressed as a percent here from 10
percent to 60 percent now let's look at
how to interpret what we see on the
graph each point represents a coordinate
where a percentage was measured for
example 10 percent in a given year here
2008 or approximately a little over 20
percent in 2010 up to about 60 percent
in 2014 so you can see that this graph
does show the change in allele
frequencies over time if you were asked
for example what was the approximate
frequency of the dark for allele in 2011
this is how you would find it go to 2011
on the x-axis and then measure up until
you hit the line and then measure over
to the y-axis this shows that in 2011
the darker allele frequency was
approximately 30% just a little bit
higher you can also do this from the
other direction
that is if you are asked in what year
did the dark fur allele make up 50% of
the population you go through the 50% on
the y-axis draw across and then down to
the x-axis and you would see that it is
approximately 2013 sometime during 2013
when the 50% mark was reached so this is
how you interpret graphs to discover
biological trends that's it for today
thanks for watching